hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher one of the things that I love
most in the current sort of educational
milieu is the real recognition through
work of people like Carol Dweck and Joe
bola about the growth mindset and how
important it is to give messages to our
students about the importance of
struggle and the ability for them to
grow in their capacity to actually
change their brains which i think is
amazing but I think often we stop at
applying it to students and we don't
realize we also need to apply it to
ourselves as teacher that's all
professional learning is is the
application of a growth mindset to us as
educators and I think it's really
important that you know as a leader of
no 2010 mathematics teachers in my
school they all come from very different
backgrounds and I want them to be able
to wherever they are coming from to grow
and I think it's also important to not
think about this in two in linear terms
like some people are at 30% and some
people are at 75 and I just want to move
them forward even though I do want to
move them forward I think people need to
be moving outward I think actually
growth is the perfect metaphor because
you know you have a look at different
plants different trees and they're all
going to grow in different ways some
vines are amazing as spreading out over
this huge different you know space of
some trees just go straight up and
they're just amazing the redwoods in
these forests that are hundreds of years
old everyone comes with a different
background different skill set and I
think cultivating that diversity and
recognizing those strengths that are
unique to among my staff people who've
come into teaching from industry people
who maybe came from primer or a
different subject people who have just
been all-in with maths their entire
lives every single one of them brings a
different set of skills and and their
ability to teach a diverse range of
students actually hinges on their
ability to to maximise on the strengths
that they have to take those spots where
they perhaps may be naturally weak and
sort of bolster them with the skills of
their colleagues I think that's why team
teaching is such a powerful mechanism to
use in the classroom because there's
nothing quite like even though you may
talk about things in the staff room and
say oh that's a great idea I'll bring
that into my my classroom it's totally
different to see it actually work live
even if it
take sixty kids in the room to have to
make that happen I I love seeing the way
other teachers just speak and interact
with kids and the questions that they
ask things like that there's no
substitute to watching it live and to
even be able to interact with us so I
think those kinds of strategies for
helping our teachers have those
conversations about improvement but also
see how it can happen and see how they
can grow in a variety of ways in the
classroom I think that that's our
responsibility as mathematics leaders
[Music]